hi
i'm shannon from khan academy and i want
to show you how to make the most of your
learning time
first make sure you're logged into your
khan academy account by checking for
your name in the upper right hand corner
if you are not logged in you won't be
able to view your assignments and any
progress you make won't be counted
towards your classes now on the left
hand side you should see your classes
where your teacher has given you a
mastery goal or an assignment to work on
click on the tab that says
assignments to view assignments from
your teacher
on the assignments tab you can see all
your upcoming and past due assignments
assignments with the nearest due date
will appear at the very top of the list
now that you're ready to go
let's talk about the top five things to
know about assignments on khan academy
number one
types of assignments
there are two main types of assignments
you can receive on khan academy
the first type is practice noted with
the star symbol
practice can be an exercise quiz or unit
test
when you complete practice on khan
academy you receive instant feedback
after every answer
answer all questions to complete the
assignment and receive a score
[Music]
the second type is instruction
noted with the play symbol and the paper
symbol
instruction can be in the form of videos
or articles
videos and articles can help you learn
new skills or review things you learned
in class
all videos have subtitles so you can
easily follow along number two
if you're stuck take a hint
it's normal to feel stuck when you're
learning new skills but the important
thing is you don't give up
take a hint to get step-by-step
instructions to the specific question
you're working on
we recommend that you write these hints
down so you can reference them later
you can also try watching a video or
reading an article on the skill
even if it hasn't been assigned to you
you'll find the videos and articles
related to each skill you're practicing
by clicking the stuck or get help link
once you've done that you're ready to
retry the practice exercise
and if you're still stuck reach out to a
classmate teacher or a family member for
support
number three be patient and persistent
not happy with the score you received on
a practice exercise
trust me we've all been there
but remember on khan academy you can
always retry assignments until you earn
a score that you're proud of
click try again to retry
[Music]
you can also return to assignments where
the due dates have passed to try to
improve your score
struggles and mistakes are what helps
your brain grow so keep persisting
number four
check your progress
on the left hand side
select progress
under my account
from here you can review all of the
activity on khan academy
this includes exercises you completed
videos you watched or articles you read
depending on your learning goals you may
want to filter to view a certain type of
content or activity
and for each practice you completed you
can view your current mastery level
the number of questions you answered
correctly
and how much time you spent on the
activity
it's helpful to regularly check your
progress so you know if you're on track
to meet your goals
number five
make khan academy your own
and finally
adjust khan academy to work for your
unique learning style
you can slow down
speed up
or rewind the videos when you need to
you can learn in the language you're
most comfortable with
khan academy is available in over 50
languages and you can easily switch
between languages in your settings
and if you prefer you can complete
assignments on a smartphone
just download the khan academy app on
android or ios
and remember
you have the potential to succeed
keep trying keep making mistakes and
keep asking for help when you need it
there is no limit to what you can learn